now sky news understands that ukrainian
forces have started an operation against
russian troops in a key russian occupied
part of southern ukraine hassan was
seized by russian forces in the early
days of the all-out invasion but there
are now moves on the ground to reclaim
it it comes amid growing concerns around
the safety of the zaparizia nuclear
power plant which has been occupied by
russian troops since march our security
and defense editor deborah haynes joins
us now from central ukraine tell us a
bit more about this operation then to
retake harrison
[Music]
well there's been a lot of movement on
the ukrainian side in recent weeks
counter-offensives launching attacks
against
key
key supply routes for the russian forces
in that southern region of hassan
including hitting railway bridges road
road bridges and also ammunition
supplies
but what we've been told and what um a
ukrainian military official has said is
that an offensive operation has begun
today uh it's it doesn't it's not clear
if this is the all-out counter-offensive
that people had been expecting could
come
remember ukraine is relying heavily on
western weapons and it would need a
certain level of western supplies and
also train troops to use those weapons
to be able to launch a counter offensive
but commanders would also be weighing up
the fact that time is running out before
we slip into the winter months when
suddenly conducting military offensives
becomes an awful lot more difficult to
give you a sense of the mood tonight
amongst ukrainian officials
one of the president's advisers took to
twitter earlier saying that the only
possible options for negotiations with
russia is being conducted by a special
ukrainian delegation in the southern and
other directions of the front line and
he quoted negotiations are going well we
expect new compromises in the form of
gestures of goodwill clearly a hope that
by putting pressure on russian forces
then ukraine can gain a further
advantage but one more point to make
that while yes it does seem that
ukrainian forces according to their
officials are making this push
in the south the front line is vast
there are multiple flash points there's
huge concern right now around the
nuclear plant in zaparilla
it's under russian control there have
been clashes around there intensifying
in recent days and a team from the un's
uh and nuclear watchdog the iaea is
coming to ukraine this week specifically
to visit the plant because of safety
concerns
if one of those attacks were to hit a
reactor and trigger a nuclear disaster
that would just add a new and more
horrific dimension to an already bloody
war